okay so things are not moving as quickly
as we would like to see but things are
happening in terms of coronavirus
treatment so I want to update that now
over time there's going to be so much
more happening that I can't
realistically in one video squeeze
everything in so what I'll do is I'll
quickly update you on what we've had up
until now and then I'll get to the new
stuff so coronavirus being a virus not a
bacteria we're looking at vaccines
antivirals and antibody treatments not
antibiotics there are now vaccines
entering stage one clinical trials on
humans first step is make sure that the
vaccine is remotely safe not causing
terrible side effects then you start
following volunteers with different
doses usually over a year see what's the
effective dose antibody generation etc
were in that process number two
antivirals I already told you about REM
des aver and a began these are being
tested on small groups of patients both
have significant side effects and only
possible efficacy anecdotal evidence so
far we need the results of the trials
that are ongoing and then lastly on
Monday I told you about some antibody
treatments multiple labs and researchers
exploring antibody transfusions from
patients who have recovered that's
pretty inefficient right now you need
antibodies from one recovered patient
can be used on one sick patient with
risks so that's just an idea right now
that's what we covered Monday let's now
get to the new stuff chloroquine is
being tested chloroquine may be better
pronounced chloroquine is a malaria
prophylactic and treatment it's not new
chloroquine has been around since 1934
it's available generic it's cheap we're
talking pennies to a few dollars per
dose there are already some papers on
this including one called expert
consensus on chloroquine phosphate for
the treatment of novel coronavirus
pneumonia Elon Musk recently tweeted
about chloroquine I believe he was given
chloroquine when he actually had malaria
if I recall correctly got people
more attention to it what does the study
say the study says that so far quote we
found that treating the patients
diagnosed as novel coronavirus pneumonia
with chloroquine might improve the
success of treatment shortened hospital
stay and improve patient outcome this is
early research it's up in the air we
also heard from French research
professor DDA Rao who said that the
first kovat 19 patients he treated with
chloroquine saw a rapid and effective
speeding up of their healing process a
decrease of how long they remained
contagious that's good news
we need more testing all right he said
we were able to ascertain patients who
had not received the drug containing
chloroquine were still contagious after
six days but of those that got
chloroquine only 25% were still
contagious small sample but that's good
we also have a new US academic study
that says the same it's a study called
an effective treatment for corona virus
it's by todaro and Regan O which says
the use of chloroquine is showing
favorable outcomes in humans infected
with corona virus including faster time
to recovery and a shorter hospital stay
promising need to keep researching then
we've got a lot of noise about
interferon alpha to be a bunch of
articles from Cuban media claiming that
this is a cure we don't know yet there's
hope that this antiviral interferon
alpha 2 B could help it has helped with
viruses similar to kovat 19 and we just
don't know yet and the idea is again use
these medications to prevent cases from
getting as serious and then lastly
there's the idea of using two drugs
Lapine aveer and ritonavir in
conjunction with chloroquine or not and
there are studies which show that in
vitro Lupino vir and ritonavir sometimes
combined with chloroquine can a work
against viruses like corona virus again
this is in vitro we have no clinical
studies on patients so it's early like
said keep isolating it's not fun it's
boring for a lot of people I want to go
out see my friends hang out at cafes not
worry at the grocery store I get it but
we've got to work together to save lives
and reduce transmission until we make
progress things are happening there are
a lot of things in the hopper sort so to
speak we have to let the doctors and the
scientists do their thing in the
meantime don't fall for any scam cures
and I'll talk more about that later on
in the program